we're joined now by former jacksonville
jaguar and like i said one of the top 40
under 40 taste makers named by wine
enthusiasts will blackman what do you
pair trevor lawrence's first nfl start
with if you're watching the game at home
would you start with yeah
listen as long as long as urban's not in
the cabinets messing with the wine then
you know what then you know i would pair
him
with some taco luz which is a famous
taco spot in jacksonville
they they actually they have a hamburger
taco cheeseburger taco legit
so
trevor lawrence gets his first nfl start
you're a jacksonville jaguars fan you're
sitting on the couch let me give let me
get this cheeseburger taco to watch the
quarterback of the future how about for
the first game here out at sofi the rams
uh play just about a nine iron away from
the rich eisen show studios week one
against the bears do you think it's a
big body barolo kind of game
big body barrel kind of game here you
know what i don't know
i'm curious it's still going to be warm
so you don't you don't want anything big
body you want something cool you know
like a maybe a
chablis from france you know it's crisp
acidic it's fun
that's sofi or maybe actually you know
what being that is sofi
you got to get something from stan
cronkite you got to get honata you got
to get his wine so we got to keep it
keep it in the family
the nfl doesn't get as much conversation
around wine as the nba does we've been
talking at length on this show about
chosen family from channing frye and
kevin love we've been talking about how
cj mccollum turned his
room at the nba bubble into a wine
cellar making sure that his 80 bottles
of pinot noir were chilled exactly right
who are the big wine guys around the nfl
on a real level because you were like i
said one of the top 40 under 40 taste
makers from wine enthusiasts well think
about it though like
these guys are always on the road right
and there's only what 12 15 guys on the
roster you can have a dinner
every time you're on a roll with 12 or
15 people
so i mean and that's what they're doing
to hanging out where
we can't have dinner with 43 guys at a
restaurant every time we go out that
wouldn't be as as fun and um i feel like
too
being that it's lebron that's leading
the charge
the best player you know in the nba
then obviously that's going to get a lot
of attention but in terms of the nfl i
mean
first of all
i like to give a lot of credit to guys
like charles woodson and andrew bledsoe
because they're they're making one like
charles has had his own wine since 2005.
drew bledsoe actually lived on the
vineyard in washington and they're
making wine so i think
i give the slight edge to nfl in terms
of make a wine but in terms of
consumption is definitely the nba guys
like i don't think we're even close
but i know like a couple of my clients
is like like matt ryan right he was my
teammate at bc and i helped him curate
his wife seller and he has a huge
collection i know matt stafford has a
huge collection sydney rice he has a
huge collection so there's a couple of
guys out there but nba by far it's not
even close
will blackman joins the show super bowl
champion and sommelier we had quentin
richardson on the other day will who
suggested that tj jefferson build a wine
cellar to preserve his air jordans
because he noticed that
the souls were falling off as their
jordans
preserving wine a lot of rumors out
there thinking that the older the better
but for the everyday drinker out there
what are a few things they need to be
aware of to preserve their wines at home
say if they want to pair it with
tampa bay new england when tom brady
returns to gillette stadium
listen you're going to need a beer for
that game
there's no wine for this you need beer
and whiskey for this one but the biggest
thing is you want to keep it of a
sunlight you know you don't want
somebody to mess with the temperature
also
you want to keep it away from a lot of
like vibration because that can
interrupt
the wine as well too and you do want to
store it on its side because the
important thing is you want the wine to
be in contact with the cork um so that
it actually stays that the exact size
when it becomes too um
the cork becomes hard
air can get into the wine and actually
expedite the agent also can make the
wine fall so you definitely want to
store it properly like that so yeah but
for that patriot buccaneers game it is
spirit it's hard liquor and it's beer no
wine will be consumed that day
i thought because of tom brady you'd
just be sitting on the couch chugging
kombucha will blockman joins the show
ben lyon's in for rich and rice on the
rich eisen show
uh these london games here on the west
coast they start early what's a good
breakfast wine
oh you know what when in doubt it's
champagne for me i know people want to
say mimosas but it's champagne because
champagne goes with anything or you can
just call it sparkle one cabba cremont
whatever it is sparkling wine is the way
to go in the morning brockman can you
imagine sitting on the couch on a sunday
morning with jacksonville ready to kick
off from across the pond and you open a
bottle of champagne to start a three-day
like three-game parlay for the sunday
it's happening yeah no absolutely it's
happened last year it's gonna happen
this year like get ready
champagne watching the jags i've gone
out there with jacksonville we had to
play in the crack of dawn it was i'll
tell you what though one thing about
playing in london um
so i was fortunate to play super with
the giants
that was damn near the closest
experience
uh to a super bowl was playing at
wembley
it was absolutely
madness
i mean i think i saw a bubby brisker
jersey in the stands um
they had all kinds of jerseys out there
so it was super cool it was exciting
will blackman joining the show former
nfl defensive back super bowl champion
and sommelier
top 40 under 41 enthusiasts taste makers
i gotta give some props to patrick
mahomes he's bringing whataburger to
kansas city and missouri
as you now enter this next phase in your
career do you pay attention to some of
the investments guys are making
especially in the food and beverage
space
i do pay attention because
it's funny we have all these meetings um
with like nfl guys or
finance guys that come in and
you know you're kind of like you don't
really think ahead
in terms of your future and what you
should be doing and
i really love the fact and respect that
the guys are making these moves now i
mean you're seeing you're seeing more
and more especially with the whole you
know
more than an athlete you see all the
things that lebron has done more
athletes are starting to or be smarter
with their money and
making wiser decisions for obviously
future investments so
i think it's cool i think it's
impressive and i i love the fact that
guys are starting young and learning now
because
once you get to part two it's different
you know you want to make you want to be
able to learn how to have your money
make money you know it's because once
you learn to do that because it's way
harder to keep trying to make money so
learn how to have your money make money
if that makes sense
well you tweeted out four words that got
brockman fired up
mac 10 live tonight
let's go will
10 is in the building let's go listen
i'm actually it's funny i became good
friends with dub c uh
the other member of westside connection
and his son
actually is a really good high school
running back
and so it just reminded me of that
that's why i had to throw it out there
but yes mac 10 he's switching and
switching his number today for 50 to 10.
i would actually like to see him in 50.
that would have been cool
what do you expect from him on the field
what do you expect from him on the field
and would you suggest maybe like a crisp
chardonnay for tonight's game
i don't know i saw that combine body
there's no wine in that body
this cigar the bud light in that body i
don't know
i don't know about that
real black majority you're so funny with
these wine pairings no one here's the
thing
when i went to green bay
yes that's where i really start to take
interest in wine and it was huge because
charles woodson was also on the team and
he was a huge obviously huge wine guy
and that made me more comfortable drink
wine but
i
green bay is a beer town
and i love me a cold beer so when it
comes to yes football and wine is great
but sometimes man you just you just
gotta crack open a milwaukee's beast not
a best beast the beast
the beast yeah we've been reminiscing uh
here as we've been catching up on some
of the old uh beverages of choice that
we had over the years some have
horrified us from our past others have
brought back uh many a fond memory of
many a knight forgotten will blackman
joining the show ben lyons in for rich
on the rich eisen show
uh getting uh into the football of it
all are you one of those guys who this
time of year you're driving around
looking for friday night football games
to just cry like ross tucker and watch
the star spangled banner are you just
away from the game want nothing to do
with it
no i you know what i was just gonna say
i'm not that creep that just watched any
football but then again my wife's
listening she's probably not in her head
like yes you are that creep that just
grows
no i i don't here's the thing people
always ask me this question they go hey
like do you miss it and i i hate when
guys like ah no i don't miss it you know
maybe the camaraderie hell yeah i miss
it i miss it like crazy
think about it
playing football in the nfl was the only
thing
i ever wanted to do
that was it i had nothing else i just
wanted to play football i've been
blessed to play 12 years
and you know i'm very happy with part
two you know obviously the main thing to
be home with my wife and kids way more
um that's my most important investment
but
i always miss playing because that's
what i wanted to do so yes i'll watch
i'll watch any kind of football
i'm actually
headed to houston because i'm gonna be
uh an analyst for those flag football
games so i'm calling games for flag
football i will watch any football i'm
actually trying to tonight i'm trying to
take our son to go watch his friend
who's
10 years old play football have football
practice so
yes i am the psychopath that watches any
football
i'll see a kid throwing a football he's
he'll throw a duck and i'll pull over
like hey listen kid this is how you
throw a spiral
awesome that's amazing that's amazing
yeah the passion
just throw me a coca-cola
the passion for the game you can't you
can't take away from you guys will
blackman joining the show ben lyons in
for rich the rich eisen show but
wouldn't that be messed up like if if
you're a pro football player okay you
play golf if you see a gun you're with
somebody and he's just like slicing him
wouldn't you like tell him to adjust his
grip a little bit right yeah that was
four hours of my life yesterday playing
with chris brockman
so if i'm driving if i'm in a park and i
see a kid just throwing ducks and me
being a pro football player like i would
be a disservice to not go help that kid
out a little bit
it'd be a disservice that you have no
choice but to pull over the car and
start coaching up some random kid on the
side of the road you have no choice
no choice
now we saw jerry jones put a lot of salt
on his mcgriddle i don't know what do
you pair with a mcgriddle what kind of
wine goes with a mcgriddle he put salt
on a make griddle
a lot of salt yeah you didn't see that
on hard knocks will yeah
no i didn't i did not see that on her
knocks wow well he puts a lot of salt on
it you need you need something that's
going to combat that salt something
that's you know actually the great thing
is salt goes with any kind of wine
really it won't make anything stringent
less or more so i don't know i don't
really eat mcgriddles
yeah it was kind of a weird but it was
did it have syrup on it no it was kind
of a weird moment like i said anytime
you're turning to a pancake for a
support you've already lost it's
supporting the rest of the sandwich so
we're already in a bad situation uh but
tj jefferson got really fired up because
that's the owner of his favorite
football team and he's putting salt now
cj's just throwing he's like salt bae
over there they were just throwing salt
on everything
um he let salt bae feed him did you ever
have hard knocks on one of your teams
have you ever
were you ever into hard knocks over the
years no like it was not in hard knocks
at all i wasn't even like playing
against the team on heart
[Laughter]
yeah it's now there's some
self-awareness the guys know they're
being filmed so you can tell which guys
are kind of performing and putting it on
of all your teammates though who would
have loved to have been on hard knocks
you think
um probably
oddly enough i think only if you steal
that al harris though he was he was
probably one of my funniest teammates
of all time
he was hilarious i think josh norman
would have loved to be on hard knocks
when i was in washington because he was
a massive ham
he was i love him he was so annoying
um he was he
look i remember in meetings he loved uh
lifesaver
gummies but for some reason he would not
i think he
discarded all the red ones
so
when i would like go to the bathroom and
come back i would look on my ipad and
see a bunch of red
lightsaber gummies and i thought he was
the strangest man in the world
i love you said i love him he's so
annoying that tells me that you guys are
really close i love that that's great
yes
appreciate you spending some time well
enjoy the season and enjoy uh a nice
cabernet from paso robles it's called
alexander that's from sashavuyachich i
think you'll find it quite delicious
yes you know paso is popping right now
obviously dao is
holding it down and
um
book or wines is really good book of
vineyards excuse me
up there and obviously everyone was like
awesome hope that's like there it's like
the new meow me or something like that
i'm sure you're already on the list but
you got to get on carmelo's wine
newsletter it's called what's in your
glass every monday great selections on
pinots from the willamette valley
carmelo doing great stuff in the wine
game
carmella is legit there is no
question about it so i'm scared to hang
out with carmilla when we do
yeah see some of those bottles he's
popped with jimmy over in france that
that might be like half your nfl career
earnings i appreciate it
but that's the problem they're scaring
everybody away with those expensive ass
wines
i feel you man can't you can't you can't
be scared away from these expensive
wines you got to get in there with a
price point that's sensible which is why
i think you'll enjoy the newsletter
what's in your glass every monday from
carmelo anthony thanks so much will
appreciate you guys well blackman
joining the show hey you watched all the
way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here